okay so upgrade's probably one of my
favorite films of the last 10 years and
I think it's massively underrated when
it comes to Sci-Fi movies with the
advances in AI made over the last couple
of years I also think it's going to
become even more relevant feeling like a
superhero film mixed with black mirror
it's a groundbreaking tail laced with a
really dark side to it throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
the movie and going over all the hidden
details and trivia within it the new 4k
for its just released worldwide and this
allowed me to spot things I'd never seen
before really enjoy diving into it and
if you do as well please hit the thumbs
up button and also subscribe if this is
your first time here welcome to the
heavy spoiler show I'm your host Paul
AKA your YouTube downgrade without the
way huge thank you for clicking this
let's get into Lee when else upgrade
hello
yes
and the film itself was originally
titled stem which is the name of the AI
that ends up taking over gray stem
stands for science technology
engineering and maths and in Dutch the
word also means voice it's clearly made
to sound similar to how from 2001 and
like that it has a sort of common
reassuring voice that lures you into
trusting it this mission is too
important for me to allow you to
jeopardize it directly when Al wrote the
first draft back in 2011 with Logan
Marshall Green being cast as the main
role one thing the actor really brings
to the performance is how he moves and
acts like his body and head are separate
entities gray becomes paralyzed from the
neck down and the Stemmons of
controlling the rest of his body this is
why there's that feeling of separation
and this also comes across to the fight
scenes themselves there's a brilliant
moment during the first person gray
takes on where the character he's
battling takes a swing for his head stem
only has control of Gray's body from the
neck down and thus it pushes his head
out the way just to avoid the punch
there's also some really creative shots
in this with the camera work being
positioned to follow his head because
this is gray this was actually achieved
by attaching a phone of the actor and
having an Alexa mini track the phone's
gyroscope he gives the fight scenes
their own unique style and on top of
this they've also got incredible
choreography everything about this film
it works so well bringing brutality and
a feeling of just how powerful stem is
to me the film's a metaphor about how
technology is taking over our lives and
it asks how much power we're willing to
hand over throughout the movie gray
becomes more immoral line on stem and he
ends up allowing it to take over more of
his life it initially just starts off as
the fight but slowly he gives more
control to stem to do the things he
can't bring himself to I feel like this
is a comment on how you've given AI more
and more power and initially it just
started off with things we couldn't be
bothered with now though it's becoming
more controversial due to its usage in
Creative aspects and it's a Hot Topic
going on in Hollywood right now feel
like when almost like read this point
where we've gone so far in that we're
actually struggling to get control back
now I really feel like if we get AI to
write scripts and make art that we're
robbing ourselves of our creative
Outlets back in the day I used to draw
just to draw and it would relax me and
make me feel like I'd really accomplish
something now people are happy to just
have computers generate things and I
feel we're stripping ourselves of the
things that make us human AI being part
of Everything Seen right from the
beginning and the movie studio titles
themselves are even read out by an AI
voice
on the commentary when all said he'd
never seen a title sequence like this
before and that he instantly wanted to
throw us into this computer heavy world
it's such a great way to set the tone
for this movie and every aspect of it is
relying on machines the self-driving
cars drones working for the police and
even crimes are solved through using
computer algorithms this is how gray
gets away with it for so long because
the police system just lists them as not
being a viable candidate it somewhat
stops the investigation there and
detective Cortez has to override it to
get down to the truth I agree someone
who starts off extremely old school and
we join him in his garage fixing up a
car this is a 1977 Pontiac Firebird
Trans Am which also shows up in Smokey
and the bandits we can also hear the
song Smoke Stack Lightning which was
released in 1956 by the artist Howling
Wolf on the desk he has a bowl with a
photograph some watches and also a roll
of dollar bills and as we pan up we see
magazines and also some invoice books
all of these are things that have been
replaced by digital counterparts with
photographs and vinyl being phased up by
technology there's also stuff like
QuickBooks we're now pretty much a
cashless society and even watches you
know phones are built where people just
look at them for the time now on the
commentary Ronaldo said he's a big fan
of opening shots like this I tell you
everything you need to know about the
central character siding back to the
feature he discussed how that opens up
as well and it's meant to show how old
school that gray really is we're never
really given a specific year for the
film either but there are Clues later on
that we can use to piece it all together
Gray's wife ashes autopsy papers reveals
she was born in 2008 and they state that
she died at the age of 38. this means
that it's roughly around the year 2046
depending on what month she was born and
then what month that we're in now wanted
to have people thrown off by the intro
which made it seem like the film was
said in the past this illusion is broken
when Asha arrives in her car and we are
supposed to question what the hell's
going on now we can catch gray working
on a car for Aaron Keane and while he's
doing this he accidentally cuts his
finger he ends up sucking it to stop the
blood and at the end of the movie after
stems taken over he also does this as
well demonstrates to me that he's taken
over his whole life and I think these
two shots marry each other to hammer
that idea at home up until that point
stem couldn't control the head but him
tasting For the First Time shows that
he's in control also the first thing he
tastes is blood witch yeah the killer
machine now has a taste for blood A1
film analysis there now we learned that
because gray is so old school at stem
purposely sort him out due to the fact
that he doesn't have any modifications
stem's whole goal was to possess a
normal person and this would allow him
to actually become human now gray says
to the car
I love you and this first line of
dialogue shows that he can get attached
to machines I also think it's important
that he's in the driver's CT air whereas
at the end he's simply just a passenger
at this point Asher arrives in her car
and we can see how different that the
pair are this car is actually a Honda
Accord from 1983 and it got stripped
down to its Bare Bones and then built up
to look like this there's a honeycomb
pattern on it to evoke and imitate
nature but it's slightly Off the Mark
and unable to fully do it everything she
has is completely automated including
the house which is voiced by an AI
called Kara this having a female name
obviously plays off Alexa which was
released back in 2014 and as I said
earlier when I wrote this script in 2011
and some of the things in this movie it
shows how on the ball he was she
suggests that they put a pizza instead
of going and making one and this shows
how food Creations become automated too
now from this point the pair traveled
out to Aaron's house who as we learn was
the developer of stem I was wondering if
Aaron was a play on Elon but they did
mention it anywhere in the Blu-ray
commentary what they did mention though
is that to get into character Lisa Tim
imagine your parents let you get raised
by computers he definitely gives that
kind of performance and is slightly
unnerving uh and it makes sense because
he's also being controlled by a machine
now we get a quick cut to the skyline of
the city yeah we see how skyscrapers now
dominate the landscape the trees in
Greenery have been incorporated into the
buildings themselves because where they
stood has now fully been built upon
another movie is set in the US the film
was actually shot out in Melbourne which
is leonel's Hometown according to IMDb
trivia you can catch the bulb bridge
over the Euro River and this comes at
roughly the 5 minute 45 Mark in
Australia they drive on the correct side
of the road we'll say so they flip this
image to make it seem like the us at the
entrance to Aaron's house is located in
a rock which I'm thinking is being
picked because he's so detached from
reality you know the saying have you
been living under a rock and when we
meet the guy he's clearly not attached
to society it's also indicative of
something beneath the surface which is
the same as what stem does to gray it
makes sense symbolically that the layer
would be in this position and as they
walk in Aeron then says you're early and
this is because he drove himself instead
of using an automated car these would of
course be fitted not to pass over the
speed limits or as humans tend to go
over it to get to places quicker now
Aaron is still working away on his Cloud
which no no prices for guessing what
that means we're not doing film analysis
A1 for you mate again this dies back to
Something in nature though but it's fake
and simulated which has undertones in
the film also we discover Aaron's
companies called vessel and stem of
course uses gray as a vessel now Asher
at this point mentions the company she
works for which we learn is in fact
called Cobalt I'm in the industry too I
work for um Cobalt at about the 9 Minute
7 Mark we actually get a wide shot of
the city and can see both vessel and
Cobalt headquarters right beside each
other now if you recognize the name well
done mate you're getting that A1 film
analysis award and this is because it
showed up in The Invisible Man early on
in the film Cecilia opens up a news
article on her phone that talks about
the apparent death of her ex-boyfriend
Adrian the opening paragraph talks about
how he was the couple founder and that
movie was also written and directed by
leonell it's thought that these two
films are set in the same universe but
they're just happening at different
times I'd love to see when I'll add more
movies to this universe down the line as
I think about this in The Invisible Man
are absolutely incredible films and we
actually have a full breakdown on that
if you want to check it out but from
here we go the sea stem itself this
purposely looks like a bug because it's
meant to be parasitic in nature and gray
also brings up a comment on AI in
general I mean look at that widget you
see the future I look at that thing I
see 10 guys on an unemployment
now at the moment where the Hollywood
strikes AI is a very big talking point
and whatever side you agree with you
have to admit this comments becoming
even more relevant anyway in the car
gray tries to touch the wheel but the
vehicle doesn't actually want him to
steer it
please do not touch the steering wheel
while the car is in motion now this is
symbolic of the movie's ending because
he's just become a passenger who can't
take control Asha also foreshadows this
as well and we get this exchange heading
to the final scene okay so what's a guy
like me supposed to do when his widget
starts taking over the wall
can enjoy the ride
come the end of the film Gray's put into
a sort of simulation where he imagines
waking up in the hospital and Ash is
still alive he's very much just given in
and handed over the control and is now
with his wife sitting back and enjoying
the ride now being unable to control the
car is what ends up leading to a
crashing as stem takes over and drives
it off the road from these early moments
it wasn't complete control of his life
steering and driving for him exactly how
it won it at this point Fisk and his
gang arrive who've been instructed by
STEM to destroy his entire life as Fisk
reaches in you can actually see the gun
markings on his hand and as we learn he
has weapons built into his arm outside
we also see as he touches Ash's chin and
on his wrist there's a circular barcode
tattoo these are revealed to be military
issue with the entire crew being people
who injured in combat and then uses Lab
Rats stem lady uses the footage from the
Drone as a way to help great track fisks
men with these tattoos being the thing
that help dig them out I'm guessing that
stem also controlled the Drone too and
this also goes down in Gray's old
neighborhood to make his past a painful
place to think about wait how sorry this
is oh this is my old neighborhood now at
this point Fisk shoots him in the neck
and we learn that this is actually an
injection that paralyzes his body this
will later be at the point at which
stems injected into him and showing why
this part specifically was targeted on
his body bit of behind the scenes info
as well if you look closely this is
actually the Nintendo gun that used to
get with duck hunt after I stay in the
hospital we cut it three months later
and see gray returning back home in a
wheelchair this is Gray's Nightmare and
unlike the past he now has to rely on
technology to help him out with
everything on the robot arms we can also
spot the name Canova and this is
actually a real-life technology company
that creates robotics for personal
assistants even making himself a drink
is something that he now has to rely on
and him being bound to the chair again
just makes him a passenger machines
don't have the human touch he needs and
they're even unaware that his wife's
dead may I ask if Asha will be joining
us for dinner it's just a cold a robotic
feeling to the entire thing and whereas
he once had a home full of love it's now
just an empty prison going to the police
station we learn the entire things run
by machines and though it helps in some
aspects it hinders in others for example
the drones and so on tend to use facial
recognition which is why fisk's gang
will cover theirs up bisc ended up
lowering his to show his face but this
caused tension in the group because they
knew the tech could track them
I bet he already knows that stem has his
back which is why he isn't bothered
about showing off his face we also learn
that criminals can put firewalls in
place and potentially stems done this to
stall the investigation at home we see
gray trying over us on Medicine by
instructing the machine to keep
administering dosages Great Falls
unconscious which is when he sent to
hospital and this location becomes a key
scene later in the movie now its use a
chair is for Aaron to visit him and
offer him a new life through using stem
at the end this is where he sees Asher
arriving too who in many ways is giving
him a brand new life both the moments in
which he ends up giving up control and
agreeing to allow stem to be brought
further into his life again it's sort of
like poetry they rhyme and I love how
these two scenes mirror one another
Aaron and gray you also talk about his
masks and masks of course have yet
become even more relevant now I don't
leave my house very often now Aaron
barely gets to leave his house because
as we know stem's there keeping him
prisoner too if you look closely you can
even see has an earpiece which the AI
uses to instruct him in the outside
world the scene very much becomes a deal
with the devil in which you'll get to
walk but he'll also become a lab
experiment operated on we almost get a
bird's eye view of the situation and can
catch X-rays of gray as we move through
the panels obviously the doctors on the
ground they can't see this angle so this
is actually stem looking down on what's
Happening implanted with the device gray
is initially blown away and a lot of
other machines also trying to act normal
just the way he runs on the treadmill
has this robotic feel to it and this is
carried across when gray gets back home
the camera movement locks directly onto
the back of his neck and it gives Focus
to stem as he's now in the driver's seat
going through the Case Files The Machine
starts talking and it's at this point
they start investigating Fisk what
stem's really doing though is giving
something for gray to do that will
eventually lead to his mind breaking
this will then fully allows them to take
over and it starts off with little
commands that don't seem too intrusive
for example great command stemless
stopped talking but he then allows it to
which gives it slightly more power if
you don't want me to I will not okay
yeah don't talk so I'm not insane
you can talk again
no you are not insane they then scan the
barcode with stem saying you rebuilt the
image but looking at this I think the
quality is too low I definitely feel
like he already had it in his record so
this is why he was able to do it
perfectly also important to bear in mind
that he doesn't give gray fisks tattoo
even though that's the one that would
have shortened down the movie stem won a
greater slowly work his way up the line
taking out people one by one that will
give her more control had he gone
straight to fairsk he'd have gotten his
ass handed to him but working up through
the ranks gets great hand over more
power just relax and let me draw
even this comes with him gaining more
power and he has to reassure gray that
he has back control this makes him think
that it's something stem will give up
easily and psychologically you know it
makes gray far more trusting now gray
does the right thing and calls up the
police but the devil on his shoulder
tempts him with sorting it out himself
heading out of the guy's home we get a
similar shot from behind further
highlighting that stems the one that's
in the driver's seat guiding him through
the apartment Grays eventually caught
and we actually get a clue that this
guy's working with cobot as he looks in
the mirror we can see the name along the
bottom man this is almost frame to spell
out the man's a pot of them too before
entering stem also knows the home's
empty and it maybe we use this as a way
to help it look around at being
ex-military the guy completely
overpowers gray but when he gives up
control we see stem stepping in the
actions were all violent and over the
top and I love seeing Gray's shocked
reaction as his body kicks a crap out of
him after giving him a big Glasgow smile
we see how great happily hands over more
control because he's unable the deal
with the horror Ronaldo does an
incredible job of balancing the cool
with the fear that gray feels and this
all comes from Gaining his brand new
powers called in by Aaron for going off
on his own we also see how the police
are slowly picking up the pieces
scanning Biometrics and using voice
control we of course none of these have
become part of our everyday lives crimes
difficult to carry out and this is due
to all the Data Tracking and even Gray's
picked up pretty quickly in their
searches the way he gets away with it is
by being paralyzed but Cortez still
suspects that something's going on we
see the address come up for power Avenue
and a little bit of trivia this is
actually leonel's old home now luckily
stem can read a body language and guide
him through the interrogation so that
there's not anything here to really give
him away even offers there a chance to
stab him in the leg and this is later
ripped on in the bathroom scene it's
used as a way to hammer homies actually
paraplegic and in both circumstances it
makes people drop their gods heading to
the old Bones bar this name carries
another meaning as as the entire things
off grid and away from the eyes of the
law in the sky we see how surveillance
drones capture everything but this place
is somewhere where criminals can lie low
even see that the tail has cash only on
air and also no earpieces so nothing can
be tracked everything is also lit with
Candlelight and this is just to give it
a more analog feeling it's a complete
die with bones lining the wall further
giving the idea that it's more aimed
towards Humanity had machines been
running it it would be way more robotic
and sterile but here I feel that it has
a more human touch I also love how we
get some modifications on certain people
and there's even some that have Alvin
ears sitting at the bar elves are of
course mythical creatures normally tied
with ancient and Fantastical tales that
long ago when the world was more magical
J.R.R Tolkien was extremely
anti-industrial with Lord of the Rings
being about keeping things traditional I
feel that's carried across yeah but
either way gray taunts stolen and gets
him to take him into the bathroom which
is where he plays possum believing that
he's helping place he openly admits to
the crime and once he gets the
confession stem takes over Tomlin picks
him up and smacks his head off the
skylights which is the only time he
actually feels pain because this isn't
handled by STEM refusing to talk gray
gives over more control so that stem can
cut him up without him having to do it
himself he's handling the situation
without getting his hands dirty and this
is something psychologically that's
being used throughout War during the
early 1930s I did a lot of studies with
soldiers and found that people handed
killing better if they could detach
themselves from it now this candidates
back to firing squads when only certain
people actually had live bullets in
their guns this allowed everyone to walk
away without fully knowing whether they
actually fired the killing blow and in
the end it allowed them to keep their
hands clean cut of the Germans in places
like Auschwitz and distance killing was
used as a way to mass murder Millions
had soldiers been going into the rooms
and then shooting hundreds of people and
psychologically it would have had a much
greater effect on them however say
they're put into a gas chamber and all
the soldier has to do is tip the
chemicals to cause a cyclone B reaction
that doesn't actually connect the person
to the killings and I appreciate how
gray kind of represents that too might
be reach pulling all these things
together but being detached from someone
tends to allow people to carry out
horrendous acts when they'll also stated
he wanted to show what stems capable of
and give us the idea of how dangerous he
is stem also doesn't give back the power
straight away showing how it's starting
to ignore what he's telling it to do
okay enough
getting the name Fisk Aaron then tries
to shut stem down and he has to make a
break for it before he's taken offline
in hindsight this is stem Breaking Free
of all controls so that if Aaron ever
gets free then he can't simply
deactivate him also get some get some
dark little comedy here keep an eye on
her would you buddy
faker
there are some little jokes like this so
it's rather full now at the hackers we
see stem being shut down and this causes
gray to start limping along as he goes
through the corridor we can catch your
face in graffiti on the wall and
boosting the brightness you can see who
this is at jigsaw from the Saw movies
with this being a little nut of the
franchise that Lee will now help create
he also played Adam in the first movie
so nice little nice little pat on the
back there now creatively he worked
alongside long-term partner James one
who gets a little nod in the very next
moment Grace stumbles across a big list
of apartment blocks and one of the names
there says J1 there's also graffiti that
links in with an army switch we're now
added to give this hacker group grounds
in reality a Fisk tracks him by reading
Talon's iron plans which keeps a record
of everything he's seen this is
something that Fierce gets himself and
we later see how he also possesses the
x-ray vision too this is something that
the surgeons had when inserting stem and
it allows the user to see through walls
this is why when the security guards
from vessel come up to the apartment
he's able to shoot them right through
the walls now before that Fisk
interrogates the bar on a money who
takes a dislike to Fisk just because
he's augmented we also see how Fisk uses
Nano machines injected through a sneeze
and these make their way into Manny's
body and rip him apart from the inside
anyway the hackers we see there's people
living in VR worlds using the headsets
to stay stuck in the Sim how long do
they VR for days
weeks this ends up foreshadowing the end
with gray then saying why someone would
choose to live in a fake world I will
never understand a fake reality somewhat
allows one happiness and they also have
Jamie say
Jamie that's not my name I don't have a
name please don't ask my gender yeah I
wasn't going to do that good Jay back in
2011 when this was written had its
finger on the pulse of where all the
social topics in general were likely
gonna go the actor Kai who plays Jaime
is actually gender neutral and they
brought a lot of their own style to help
make the character at this point gray
crawls across the floor and he sees a
vision of Asher standing there before
him in hindsight I think this is
triggered by stems program starting up
and he's relaying images of Asha by
accident showing that he's got scans of
it reactivating stem pulls off an
amazing couple of flips and again yeah
great camera work really really well
done here beating fisk's right-hand man
with his left hand man makes it home
which is when his mother discovers the
truth gray has a dream about Ash is
sitting beside him man in this Vision
she's there eating pizza this was of
course what the pair were gonna make in
the film's opening and it also
highlights how stem started filling his
mind with Sims stem also shows what life
would be like without it and this
obviously leaves gray completely
powerless at this point gray could stop
all the killings but again makes a deal
with the devil to avoid being stuck like
this stem also reveals that with the
hacker they had them lifting all the
barriers so that stem now has full
control it turns out that Cortez left a
device in his pocket and this has been
listening in to what he said to stem
this leads to a Chase and racing along
the motorway Gray's the one who has to
take control because the car's not
electronic however stem can hack into
certain cause on the motorway and he
Pilots a one that looks identical to
ashes bit of behind the scenes stuff
from while in on the commentary but this
is actually the same model that they
used earlier in the movie this gives
away the twist a bit because it shows
stem control the core and that it was
the one that took it off the road also
keep going between calling stem he and
it but you know us you don't you don't
really care about that deer also inside
the car we can see a news report on a
Proto meets B firm and in case you don't
know Proto meat is a meat that doesn't
harm animals I think so so like
unfertilized eggs are Proto meat but I
don't I don't know how beef would work
but moving on anyway Greg confronts Fisk
who offers him a dealer join his side as
one of the hybrid humanoids that's the
next step in evolution gray of course
rejects this which leads to a big fight
but Fisk proves too much and he leaves
him at his whim great haunt him though
and breaks him psychologically by
bringing up the fact that he killed the
rest of his unit it shows that though
he's almost machine he's still got a
human side to him which can be broken
and that's why gray wins going to his
messages he then hears Aaron and heads
out to his home to finally finish
everything and this is where he of
course met stem and it also becomes a
place where stem takes over now instead
of finding Ariana's the calculating
Mastermind he comes across a shivering
weak man who can't control his monster
scientific discoveries have often led to
their craters being unable to put the
genie back in the bottle and it's
something also happened with the case of
Oppenheimer now he goes there to kill
Cortez but she then teases him and Aaron
draws his gun admitting he's an no
longer running the company Aaron reveals
the truth and that stem's been trying to
kill him because he's the only one that
can create another stem killing Heron
the pair then wrestle for control and to
gray believes that he actually kills
stem this sends him back to the hospital
but the first clue we get that summings
off is because this isn't the same one
that he was taken to right after the
crash so it was a shot like the ending
of The Wizard of Oz with it seeming like
he's just awoken from a bad dream in
reality though we see stems now fully
taken over and I love how his eyes have
an almost black and lifeless feel of
them this is because the characters lost
his soul and there's just something
about how lifeless that he looks moving
robotically we see there's a
machine-like position to it and gray
accepts a dream as he kisses Asher on
the lips initially you can tell from his
eyes that he's questioning it all but he
gets sucked in and takes it as his new
life it's a really chilling way to close
out the movie and even just discussing
it it still gives me goosebumps now this
was of course also used as the image for
the poster with the title telling you
straight away that this guy's an upgrade
oop heavy spoilers there and yeah that
closes out I'll break down and again
I've just had so much fun going back to
the movie the film has just released in
4k and I really recommend that you pick
it up got a commentary on there from Lee
when L and I promise you it's it's worth
picking it up for that alone because
it's absolutely hilarious learn a lot
from it and I hope you did too and if
you enjoyed the video please hit the
thumbs up we're going to be tackling the
original Star Wars Trilogy next and
Kicking It Off With A New Hope really
soon you want to get early access to
that video then please hit the join
Button as we drop all these breakdowns
there sometimes a week in advance help
stuff like this get made for less than a
price of a pound a month and it really
goes a long way to helping me and the
team out we massively appreciate it
thank you again for all your support you
know the classic movie breakdowns it
wouldn't be anywhere near as successful
without you guys so we really appreciate
you you know just helping out the
channel means a lot and yeah if you want
something else to watch you've got a
classic movie breakdown linked on screen
right now you just covered the babadook
or I'll do one that YouTube recommends
specifically for you by reading through
all your history and using it AI to
figure out which breakdown's Gonna Make
You click are you calling it a liar mate
no come and embrace the technology and
click on that video and yeah I hope you
enjoy by the way huge don't give a
second for this one I'll be important I
hope you enjoy the rest of your weekend
you take care peace
[Music]